ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
السلطات الاوكرانيه وصفت الهجوم على كييف
بانه الاكثر تعقيدا ووصفته بالاستثنائي من
الناحيه العسكريه هل ترونه كذلك
نعم عندما يكون هناك تنوع في الصواريخ في
نفس الوقت صواريخ في مجملها فرض صوتيه لكن
سرعات متباينه مسارات من حيث زاويه
الارتفاع
متباينه ويضاف الى ذلك انها جاءت من
اتجاهات مختلفه ومعززه بالطائرات المسيره
اذا الان منظومات الدفاع الجوي تواجه تحدي
اكبر وظرف اصعب في التصدي رغم ذلك جاءت
الاخبار من الجانب الاوكراني انه تم اسقاط
كافه الصواريخ هذا يعني ان سويه استخدام
الدفاعات الجويه خاصه الباتريوت
وغيرها اصبحت على درجه عالي من المهاره
والكفاءه لدى المستخدمين ان يتم اسقاط سته
صواريخ كنجال الفرد صوتيه والتي قالت
روسيا عنه في اخر اختبار الصاروخ الذي لا
يمكن اسقاطه ولكن تم اسقاطه قبل اكثر من
اسبوع والان يتم اسقاط سته صواريخ فكان
تحدي كبير واذا اخذنا بالتصريحات
الاوكرانيه فان هذا التحدي تمكنت القوات
الاوكرانيه من احتوائه واجهاضه في السياق
يعني كما اشرت فايز اذا ما اخذنا بالروايه
الاوكرانيه والروايه الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
اسقاط مثلا في في موضوع الطائرات المسيره
عن اسقاط معظم الطائرات المسيره التي
تسميها بالطائرات الانتحاريه التي تصل
هل من فكره لدى روسيا باستخدام هذا العدد
وهذا الكم الكبير من الطائرات المسيره على
شكل طائرات الانتحاريه يسهل اسقاطها
يا سيدي الان دعنا مقارنه بصيده في البعد
الاقتصادي عندما تتحدث عن صاروخ كنجال
تتحدث عن رقم فلكي لم يتم التصريح به لكن
من المؤكد انه يقارب اثنين الى ثلاثه
مليون دولار تكلفه الصاروخ الواحد عندما
نتحدث عن صاروخ اس 400 تقريبا نفس التكلفه
عندما نتحدث عن صاروخ اسكندر
لكن عندما نتحدث عن طائرات شاهد كما كازي
126 نتحدث عن بضع مئات من الدولارات
وبالتالي في البعد الاقتصادي لابد لابد من
اجل انجاح عمليه الاستهداف واستخدام
الصواريخ ان يكون هناك اهداف مهاجمه عددها
كبير جدا اي منها يجتاز منظومه الدفاع
الجوي سيلحق اضرار وبالتالي هنا سيتم
ارباك عمل
لدى منظومه الدفاع الجوي مع اي هدف تتعامل
مع الهدف الاخطر وبالتالي هنا يكون
استخدامها ذو جدوى كبيره للجهه المستخدمه
لانها تريدك الدفاعات الجويه وان لم يتم
التعامل معها وتعطى الاولويه للصواريخ
الفرض صوتيه فهذه الطائرات الرخيصه تقوم
مقام الصواريخ بدرجه ما انطلاقا من ما
ذكرتها هل بدات تتضح استراتيجيه او
تكتيكات روسيا في مواجهه ما تقول او تتحدث
عنه اوكرانيا عن هجوم مضاد كثافه عملياتها
باتجاه كيف هنالك تصعيد في المواجهات على
مختلف المحاور ما هي استراتيجيه او
تكتيكات روسيا في هذه المرحله
يعني دعيني الخص الامر في في كلمات معدوده
اولا
تصعيد متبادل وترقب متبادل التصعيد
المتبادل يطال عده مجالات استخدام
الصواريخ كما شاهدنا او تابعنا في هذا
اليوم
من بكثافه كبيره بانواع متعدده بمقاربات
مختلفه معزجه بالطائرات يقابل يضاف الى
ذلك هجمات ارضيه في العديد من المناطق
وهذه الهجمات متبادله ولكن محور هذا هذه
العمليات فخمه حتى فخمه هناك هجمات
متبادله هناك هجمات من قبل
وجماعته في محاوله استكمال السيطره لانه
الحديث عن 90 الى 95% تم السيطره عليه
وبقي حوالي واحد المربع يقابل هناك محاوله
اوكرانيه محمومه بالسيطره على ما يطلق
عليه الاكتاف الدفاعيه او الشولدرز لمدينه
باخمد هناك محاوله تقدم في عمق المدينه
يقابل هجمات من اليمين واليسار من اجل
تنفيذ عمليه احاطه واسعه تسعى الى تطويق
قوات فاجنر والقوات الروسيه التي موجوده
في داخل فخمه وهذا العمل اذا نجح اقول اذا
نجح سيغير في مقاربه هجوم الربيع لماذا
هجوم الربيع الان فقد المفاجاه
الاستراتيجيه الحديث عن المفاجاه
التكتيكيه العملياتيه والتكتيكيه
والحديث يدور في منطقه جاباروجيا باتجاه
ميني وبحر ازوف بينما الان اذا ما نجحت
القوات الاوكرانيه واقول اذا ما نجحت في
احتواء والاحاطه والصيد استعاده السيطره
على ضخمه قد يكون مقترب هجوم جديد معزز
لهجوم زبروجيا باتجاه وسط الاقاليمل التي
سيطرت عليها روسيا
الخبير العسكري كنت معنا من عمان